hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to hoonie pop
2 double date now it's been many years
since i last played hoonie pop
i'm a different person i'm more mature
i've really grown
my brain much more wrinkled and the
world has changed
back before you litzy and you weren't
even here it was matt watson
matt watson edited this but avert your
eyes this isn't for the impure
or this is for the pure this is impure
don't look at the boobs
my god don't look at the boobs anyway so
it was a different era of youtube back
when this first came out and when videos
were being made about this
now there's no chance in hell that this
is going to get monetized
recommended put anywhere on youtube it
just exists between us
and who knows how long youtube will let
that stay but hey
since we're here and since we're in
agreement let's have some fun
ah censorship um oh is that it
bros and panties all right that's gonna
have to do also it's very loud um
okay select an icon for the save file i
actually don't remember
wait no i remember lola and i remember
jesse i think
was lillian in like hoonie cam studio i
don't remember zoe
sarah vaguely lilani
polly fabia ashley
brooke nora it's been a while god how
long has it been
i do remember lola though lexian put in
like a flashback
remember to revert your eyes cause you
can't look maybe when you're growing up
maybe then you could look you see
something you like
i have to give you everything stuff this
in your face
i don't even remember if i went on a
date with lola in the last episode
well i remember lola i think i remember
jesse that was the mom right i
i'm gonna go with lola gender male
average guy
okay chad i'm an average guy you know
i'm average
polly's junk holly polly polly's junk
any audi oh
i see i'll go with any for now i'll go i
don't think you can change it when
you're playing i'll go any
i'll go any anyway now begins the
adventure
of hoonie pop two i i wish i had planned
out my weekend better because i would
have had this series start on
valentine's day
but hey a little late ain't so bad
a little late ain't the worst thing in
the world
in some circumstances a little late is
bad according to legends passed down
from
ages long past an
era of darkness and destruction draws
near
hell yeah deep within the endless sea of
stars
look at the butts on those stick figures
stirs an ancient evil
forgotten by time nice
nice nice nice ancient evil knife
lady dimmer rescue spirits
of limitless luxury lying dormant in the
cosmos
saying that like it's a bad broken only
once every 10
000 years by a cosmic
super period of unspeakable pms
with symptoms so severe and desires
so destructive entire galaxies have been
consumed by the chaos
[Music]
it said that only a hero of unparalleled
prowess
can overcome the insatiable lust of the
demonic pair
and return them peacefully to a
satisfied slumber
look hey look look
i'll volunteer for this as the dreaded
day looms upon an
unsuspecting world jesus how tall are
they church savior has risen to stand
against the threat
all rise is left defenseless
against certain doom i'll do it a
volunteer's tribute
i've all enjoyed actually
i might know somebody
me me
yeah is it me is it me i bet it's me
hi thanks man i
really needed that great
that's great how did you get in my house
and what did you just do i am unfamiliar
with you your hair your boobs
your bra and panties censorship i guess
i don't know
anyway i'll be with you in just a moment
we're all in agreement from now on we've
all grown up
from then to now we've all matured
this isn't a sex thing it's about power
it's the ultimate test of that
so everyone just cool your jets and
let's all agree
that we're going into this together and
no one's gonna make it weird
oh he's happy to help her girl i always
you're still here i thought i was dying
no cuddling uh bad always happy
yeah yeah i thought you are you animal
i'm an animal listen i'd love to stick
around and watch your dick shrink
but i got a split oh okay have a crazy
early flight tomorrow
my boss is sending me out to some island
for an exotic
shoot oh then i'm supposed to meet up
with this
telly uber chick for a cross promo we've
been planning oh
it's not easy being a world-class
fashion model you know
wow um
oh yeah that was like a big actually not
me
i didn't do that all these people just
kept leaving their underwear around i
don't know why
very strange a very platonic
relationship that i'm gonna have because
i i have been a relationship and i can't
i can't be fainted let
her see you around please
i can barely remember your name half the
time
now where did you throw my clothes
oh you know i don't there they are okay
cool there they are
good glad i could help well
aren't you at least gonna walk me back
to my car sure yes your mouth
it would be my heart
oh yes
oh god forget you man i ask you for
anything
later sweet cheeks okay that thing nice
and hard for me for when i get back
i doctor says more than four hours is
probably i should not
okay well well well look at this
[ __ ]
okay i leave you alone for a year or two
and you're banging models on the reg
huh well i mean i'm a miracle worker
yeah i mean oh cute cute how do i say
your name
cute can i purchase it
okay holy man where are you
hey you think you're my only client uh i
don't know
there's a lot of virgins out there well
i mean
none of them picked it up quite as fast
as you though
that's actually kind of why i'm here all
right cool
good i'm gonna cut right to the chase
because time isn't exactly on our side
here
okay some seriously crazy [ __ ] is about
to pop off and we need your help to stop
it
okay all right i mean this is not a
surprise to me at all i have no idea
what you're talking about but i'll do it
i don't even feel that way because i
definitely wasn't giving you a choice
okay cool that's pretty much what i
expected story short
there are these two like evil space
hookers that are about to be awoken
and if they don't get some wicked good
dick they're
probably gonna destroy the galaxy
and that would really suck because earth
has some of the finest babes in the
universe
next to tendricide what's tinder said
part of my job as a love fairy is to
find a worthy hero among
all the pathetic virgins why
unfortunately
we couldn't find one so you'll have to
do instead
thanks that hurts thank you consider it
be done uh
i've nailed it spit i did well i
shouldn't shout that
but i did i nailed a space chick
i did it i strongly advise you not to
underestimate just how horny these semen
demons can be
well i'll be honest with you man the
higher-ups are concerned about your lack
of experience with threesomes
who's high up with threesomes but i told
him you're a quick learner
besides you did bag the [ __ ] goddess
of love
i did i did do that put on some goddamn
underwear and pack your bags
our flight leaves first thing in the
morning i did that me
no one else you got it where are we
going
oh why don't we catch her hey what's
going on having a frankly
dangerous amount of unprotected sex with
strange women
oh and i've been trying to teach other
people to do the same thing
fair we're caught up well can you
believe it man
the old team back together again for
another
sexy adventure okay all right cool you
know what i'm
all right bye move my apartment
in my airplane cabin i guess
i can't believe you humans have to get
into big machines just to do something
as simple as flying
well i hate to say it but if it wasn't
for all the honey you guys generate
you'd be pretty useless it is honey i'm
never going to say it
another way it's always going to be huni
for me
[Music]
all right all right cool your nips i
guess i've made you wait long enough
we are headed to the beautiful tropical
island of
inadepuna why you may ask
i'm getting to that you can ask
questions when i'm done
in a debuna those are the space hookers
are on the verge of being awoken by
their period
if that happens you can kiss your sorry
ass goodbye
so we need to wake him up before that
there's a volcano
on the island called mount nymphojaro
yeah i don't know who names this [ __ ] if
we can get that volcano to erupt
it should be enough to awaken the
nymphogen early
but the only way to get that [ __ ] to
blow is to offer a sacrifice
a sacrifice of fairy i'm sure you're
wondering
what the hell are fairy wings i thought
i told you to stop asking questions
you ever hear the phrase whenever a
threesome is had a love fairy gets her
wings
yeah well that's actually true so we
need to get you
mixed up in some menage trois
as much as i'd [ __ ] love to be more
involved unfortunately love fairies
don't count
besides corporate said i have to stop
[ __ ] my clients
can you believe that [ __ ] huh yeah
actually locking down the three-way can
be tricky
the best way to do it is by going on
double dates okay
not the lame kind of double date where
it's two couples
the cool kind where it's you and two
chicks
all right you'll need some fresh love
fairy tech though
that crusty ass honeybee 4.0 is way out
of date
so introducing
the brand new honeybee 6xl with
threesome compatibility detection
package
go ahead check it out when you're done
you can close it by clicking anywhere
off the honeybee
cool hey look ah i remember
find her oh never mind girl nope stats
god damn it stall gifts wow
it's the only thing i packed there's a
problem i have no
any i can't wear that store nope
hair god damn it this thing's
functionality is great
thank you you can also open and close
the honeybee with a simple middle click
or tap of the space bar
you got it so uh yeah
i think that's pretty much my entire
spiel great for now at least
okay any questions no actually
seems pretty straight where do the name
why are they so horny you what are these
space cards
you're asking the wrong fairy why that
kind of
intel is way above my pay grade why
i thought i heard a familiar voice back
here
[Music]
hey stranger long time no see
no way isn't she that tight-ass flight
attendant you used to bang
oh man can i book a flight or what
small world huh i never thought i'd bump
into you on one of my routes by the way
uh who are you talking to oh yeah
that's right i'm invisible you must look
like a crazy person back here
you should probably change the subject
before it gets
any more out lola
lola hey what's up hey hey yeah
i forgot i forgot i didn't know you were
a travel guy
yeah still here oh wow i have to reduce
my hours though so i could focus on
other things
of course yeah that's it or not i
started my own little fashion design
business
you have a website and everything great
it's still young though
so i don't want to quit my day job yeah
yeah yeah no enough about me though
let's talk about you me what brings you
out i
have two in the buddha i wear
the space gods okay they're gonna be
period
but i'm gonna stop them with my dick and
i'm gonna prevent
everything from dying there's a volcano
called nympha manjaro okay
and this volcano if i don't get
two girls very happy
the mountain won't explode someone's
getting sacrificed
and then the gods arrive they're like
nympho gin
and one's blue one's red
both planet-sized tatas
and they are pissed and horny
that's the whole story you would you
wouldn't believe it
okay you yeah go ahead and keep your
dirty secrets
of course i have a suitcase for you
gonna be a little time off on the island
myself
i'm meeting up with an old friend of
mine for a little vacay we've been
planning forever
wow that's great oh so yeah
we want to join the mile high club yes
what is that lola rembrandt i don't
remember what your last name was i'm
hoping that's correct you naughty
naughty girl
i'm a mature man i it's i've grown in
the few years in between our last
meeting
i'm more refined what i work
hard a girl's gotta find some way to
relieve a little stress
exactly i'm gonna pretend i have to go
to the bathroom but
i'll leave the door unlocked wow wait a
couple minutes so you don't raise any
suspicion
okay of course of course bro
we haven't even landed yet and you're
already scoring
ass i know maybe this chick isn't as
uptight as i thought
no this is actually a great opportunity
for me to teach you about double dates
what do you say how yeah good i
i've never done that all right
well let's head in there we don't want
to keep her waiting do we
no except she said wait a few minutes so
that i didn't never mind here i go
i'm in the bathroom tutorial date we're
having a date
date date question question of the day
working i don't even know how long it's
been since i've gotten any
oh yeah all right i'll try to make this
quick because i know we all just want to
get to the good part
what's the good part you remember how
dates work right
well double dates are similar with a few
key differences
the goal is still the same you want to
fill up the affection meter before you
run
out of moves you do that by matching
three or more of these tokens either
horizontally or vertically
right well affection tokens to be exact
right affection tokens are the circular
ones with symbols on them
like those three flirtation tokens over
there go ahead and match them
what are you talking about you know the
green ones in the middle of the grid
there
with the stars on them is that a
flirtation token does that mean
flirtation what is the pink one
which one were you talking about this
one here
this bam now the biggest difference with
double dates is
obviously that there's two chicks right
you gotta learn how to divide your time
and attention between
both girls it can be a bit tricky
not for me right now you're focused on
me uh switch over to her
all you gotta do is click on her are you
is she just standing there looking at me
talking to the air yeah yeah tolkien's
affection
but then again she would already know
this deal so somehow it works she sees
me whammering on poking my finger in the
air and it just like
it gets her going that's the old
markiplier charm here
it just works no matter what easy sleazy
now that you're focused on her all the
matches you perform will go to her
oh yeah okay let's see i'm trying to
find some talent tokens for you to match
challenge oh in the bottom left-hand
corner the blue ones
put the music notes on them okay what
about them they're not
they're not what about what the no they
don't i can't ha
there's no it's not it wouldn't work
what about him
i can't what
since when since when
since when since
when matches such as four or more in a
row
will also give you more affection switch
focus back over to me and i'll show you
you can use right click as a shortcut
try it right click
there's a four of a kind romance token
match somewhere on the grid
i'll let you find it in case you forgot
romance tokens are the orange ones with
the crescent shapes on them orange
has it always been able to do that
that's this is revolutionizing my candy
crush ability
the thing with bigger matches that you
gotta watch out for
is that they also cost more stamina my
stamina is looking pretty low right now
so let's find some stamina tokens to
match
there in the top right corner of the
grid match those stamina tokens
the white pentagon things okay
that's better the last thing you want to
happen is for a girl to run out of
stamina if that happens
she'll be completely exhausted until her
stamina fully recovers
right of course we all know you remember
the other token types but i'll give you
a quick refresher just in case
thank you just in case the gold bells
are called joy tokens joy they give you
extra moves
you can't beat that no the pink hearts
are called passion tokens
matching those increases a girl's
passion
the higher her passion is the more
affection she'll give from affection
token matches affection
broken hearts work a bit differently on
double dates
but you still want to avoid them at all
costs all costs
matching broken hearts will instantly
drain a girl's stamina and put her in a
bad mood
no that's not even the worst part of it
either
no you want to know the worst part
if both girls are angry or exhausted
you're
done no you failed the date's over
so don't do that okay okay is that
everything can i shut up now
no wait gate gifts how do i
always forget about date gifts i don't
know i'm sure you didn't pack any so
i got you covered switch focus back over
to her william
what about these hello here she might
like this one
yeah or from honeycorp's newest line of
date plushies
okay as usual she'll need some sentiment
before you're able to give her the date
gift
what i'll let you find a good sentiment
token match which will look
for the teal-colored teardrops
bam you feel sentimental that should be
enough
you can give her the plushie now just
drag it over to her
i know lola i know that i am taking my
time but i am just drinking in your
beauty
really appreciating our history together
now you
have impacted me and my life love the
hair
the eyes the earrings
you lovely what am i doing you
here what this can i take
there you go honeycorp has tons of new
and classic date gifts for sale
so try them all of course and
that's it that's it those are most of
the basics of double dating
anyway i know it's a lot to take in but
don't worry you'll get the hang of it
i'm going to fumble my way through this
so we can do what we came here to do
yeah okay rather
who we came here to do
i'll make sure you can't fail this one
just try not to screw it up too bad
how do you how are you gonna make sure
you well i mean it's basically a done
deal but
how are you gonna are you part of this
you bam great where
you're welcome thank you wait no thank
you not you're welcome
do i worry about you this take one of
those
take this bam
and then one of these yep
that's what i thought and then i'm gonna
give you
one of this
i know i'm aware
just you wait and then the passions will
erupt
very shortly
the passion the passion passion
[Music]
affection what does affection do i don't
have many moves left i gotta make some
big moves i gotta make
i gotta i gotta move big
[Music]
no i i'd smack spashing already why am i
doing that
move move right move right
move right i knew i should have gotten
coffee earlier
oh yeah that's right it's the whole
stamina thing
i think i'm getting my second wind yeah
good that's awesome i'm so happy for you
just
wait the love is on the way
[Music]
have i gotten stupider
am i dumb am i dumb
and let's finish it off with a big
blast of this
done i did it i'm the best
give me the fruit what what for the
flirty sexual what
what the hell was that
are you just gonna sit and catch up or
are you gonna take that thing out
you fruit just poured out of your tits
what the hell
for the um bonus round
this is the part where you [ __ ] the
girls
unfortunately i have to sit this one out
or i'll have to go through
abstinence training again
okay the bonus round is pretty simple
just forget everything i just taught you
about double date
and match tokens as fast as you can you
got
it no matter which ones just keep
matching match
try not to stop or slow down getting two
girls to climax simultaneously requires
some serious sexterity
okay good thing i put all my points in
sexility oh god uh you
no you you yeah you shush
elixie and cover up all the noises
make it pg make it make it make it fine
it's all good it's okay
[Applause]
take it out get it away go put it away
take it away
take it away god [ __ ] was i
way too loud i have no idea he's trying
to keep it down
whatever it was replaced with i couldn't
have boned her better myself
well maybe a little better all right
fair enough
good glad hey that's a successful date
a completely platonic and
not horny date well that was certainly
refreshing good excellent hopefully
nobody saw us walk out tonight no
woof yeah no i saw a lot more than that
perfect timing too looks like we're
about to begin our descent
i better go take my seat did i get some
more still have my number right
give me a ring so we can meet up on the
island
by the way you're probably wondering why
a bunch of fruit popped out of us after
the date huh
little yeah i was a little out here in
the tropics honey takes a slightly
different
form than you're used to instead of that
weird pink jelly stuff
it manifests as what we call honey seeds
don't worry you can still use them to
bite gifts and other useful items from
the honeybee
oh look there it is i can see the island
we're almost there oh okay
i can practically taste all that
delicious clam already
okay all right man you know it's hard to
be family friendly
[Music]
ah where the melons are juicy and the
fish are plenty
okay and you kevin
go come on we're already demonetized
what more are you gonna do to us
that's literally the slogan for the
island it's right there on the side
behind you
oh also i can't look behind me oh what
the
[ __ ] is that hey
look over there isn't that your little
sex buddy from home
how convenient is that what are you
talking about
oh you um
what in the [ __ ] are you doing here
ashley ashley me
what the [ __ ] are you doing out here
don't even try to give me that [ __ ] you
knew i was coming out here didn't you
well dude if you wanted to fly out here
with me
all you had to do was ask well if i'd
have known you were coming
i wouldn't have had to explain my
vibrator to security
oh my god oh i love
her oh okay you already have an in with
this chick too
now all we gotta do is convince her to
have a three-way
okay hi harley get over there
all the way out here to ask me that yeah
cause i'm down for
three way you better find us a hot girl
though
i only said the sevens and up okay where
did you find this chick
i want one look i have some business
stuff to take care of out here
but i should have plenty of free time
too
i'm staying at what was the name
oh yeah lovely lovely hotel
lovely lovely accidents that's exactly
where we'll be staying too
well hey anyway i should probably go
find my luggage
okay don't get it confused with mine
it's full of underwear don't ask man i
am definitely sneaking into her room at
night to get a whiff of that
speaking of which we should go check in
before it gets too late
come on let's go okay cool where why
i've forgotten oh yeah space gods
sexy space gods
pretty sweet digs huh if you're gonna
try to save the galaxy
you might as well do it in style yeah
why not who's paying for this am i good
shut up just checking in thank you
actually i'm not sure i was told to come
here i'm guessing by all your luggage
that you'll be staying with us
yes all my luggage but i don't remember
seeing any more reservations in this
year
tonight well you know [ __ ] no i forgot
to do something
not a problem though oh i'm sure we can
find the appropriate accommodations for
you
oh okay cool what kind of room were you
looking for what with a bed would be
nice uh gimme uh maybe no
hey listen i am not that forward except
when i am and that's only when a fairy
tells me that i need to be forward so
that i can stop two rampaging sex
gods from consuming the galaxy i'll take
whatever's available
let's see what we have for you i know
everything on the first floor is taken
but i do have a great room for you on
the second floor
it has a nice view and a big bed perfect
i think you'll find it to be quite
suitable
yeah i flail when i slowly retrieve your
key card excellent thank you
okay oh you're back here's your key card
about much appreciated
it's written on the back if you need
anything else please don't hesitate to
ask
i will never hesitate i don't hesitate
at any moment
i'm good elevator is behind you to your
right enjoy your stay and have a
wonderful night oh
enjoy your stay nailed it
the adventure begins oh all right
sunshine hi i hope you slept well all
right we've got a full day of double
dates ahead of us
i literally blinked and here i am you
remember how the honeybee registers the
girls you meet and tracks their location
right
yeah kind of creepy well now it can also
detect the presence of girls that you
haven't even met yet
just open up the girlfinder app and
select a location where two girls are
gonna be
the honeybee will automatically detect
if the girls are compatible with each
other
if they are you can probably coax them
into a threesome
but it might take a date or two
oh oh oh oh oh
okay oh lola
lola you're going to the airport i'm
psyched usually thanks me too yeah yeah
yeah yeah i'm sorry go
go go go go go oh my god and if you
ever need to check in with me just meet
me back here at the hotel room
oh okay oh i get to go on my own now yay
i'm free i'm free why is
why is she just hanging out at the
airport hmm
i swear there was a little coffee spot
somewhere around
it might be on the other side of
security no no just slip through the
staff entrance real quick
hello i saw you commit a crime excuse me
oh hello i'm very sorry
but i don't think you're allowed to go
that way
oh no it's okay i work for tropica
airlines
i'm just gonna go grab a coffee wow
ma'am you're gonna have to show me
what's in your bra
uh bags uh i i have to check your your
bags
for security purposes only oh okay of
course yes
bags what are you talking about i don't
even have any bags
i i'm going to have to ask you to come
with me for a
body inspection are you kidding me
this is absolutely ridiculous
sorry but it's uh a policy
yes standard policy
all right fine whatever let's just get
it over with
i'm this that's is this
really necessary hey what are you
where are you oh oh my
well that was um
yeah everything uh everything
checks out am i watching am i watching
this on my face
uh wait you're you're free to go on your
way
oh lola
[Music]
don't do that [ __ ] i'm in the wrong line
of work
no i don't think you can't do that okay
she's about to pop an ovary i hate to
say it but
you might not want to turn her on any
more than she already is
i didn't do anything i'd like to see her
make the floral slippery
we need her to save that energy for
dates
how to distract her by talking about i
don't know
what's the thing that isn't sex
oh hi yeah i'm here apparently i've been
here the whole time i saw
everything what i'm thinking of a number
it's
two two space gods are about to destroy
everything unless i bone them i'm not
talking about sex with you i'm talking
about death
from sex what's that 69
yeah never mind hi huh
oh sorry oh you're saying something yeah
i was
lost that's okay i get lost in my own
brain too it's so spacious up there i
never know what's going on it's like an
echo
how are you doing my name is markiplier
nice to meet you i admire
your dedication to security i love
safety and safety in every way this is a
great job yeah i'm still
getting used to the rules though of
course yes rules
yesterday for performing too many
searches
yeah well really still quite new here
it's only been a month since
i well since i left my home country
oh that's so sad what made you want to
leave i don't want to trouble you with a
long story it's okay
i don't really fit in there so
i suppose none of that matters anymore i
live here now
on this beautiful island where there are
lots of beautiful girls wearing
bikinis and uh rubbing lotion on
themselves
goddamn it now i'm horny too oh
i guess i'll go crank this one out bye
hey i was talking hi lola officer since
we've basically been to second base do i
at least get to know your name
oh right of course my name is labia
up i mean obvia obvious
sorry
i've detected something ha my intuition
has told me that there's some kind of
connection between these two people
good thing i'm such a genius and able to
discern these incredible details
hello hi i'm considering my options
[Music]
would it be okay if i asked you
something personal we just met so
yes how would you describe the taste of
a lady
uh it's like if you poured milk into a
yeah i don't think i've ever heard that
before
you wouldn't have it's from a different
you know place
it's hard to describe hey
of course hey what's you
wait how do you how the hell do you work
out
boxing gloves down i started taking
lessons about a year ago so you better
watch out
hey okay i will not threaten you
i'm not used to people asking me about
my opinion
yeah well here comes duh just you wait
what's weather how does that [ __ ]
work huh when you're made to wear a lot
of clothing
you grow to really appreciate the rainy
days
great that's sick hey how about
we what am i doing
you're out of stamina how do we do
anything like that damn i already like
you too much to turn you down now
i'm aware you weren't doing a job right
neither of you were working
we're at the golf course
oh that's your balls for you uh wait no
that came out wrong
okay i don't
yep master of flirting me
watch this smart news i am aware
of the move and how intelligent it was
you don't need to tell me i was there
when it was made
yep
yep i should be planning
things ahead and carefully considering
my
op goal and then you go
and then this is going i'm going
you are very aware of the goal
get the passion take one of these
get ready for my hidden move
[Music]
and then i'll hit this golf ball
you can't be possibly bam there's no
mercy on the pain
leisure train
[Music]
rick skip
bro
no mercy for you
everything you thought is gone
no other one
excellent it is i know
this this move will exhaust lola
well let's hold on then
wham exhausted
i do everyone i meet is too
tired to deal with me oh
serious you i'm sorry
sorry but i have to say i'm a little
disappointed
look hey i didn't realize that was gonna
do
ah i guess i'm okay goodbye
[Music]
damn it all right courtyard well i'm not
going to let a little failure like that
get me down i have
i have failed so many times i can't even
count any other person's either
i'm glad you're here this is perfect yes
you know that famous kelly uber chick i
mentioned of course
yes any minute now to plan our collab
that's incredible yes just so happens
we're gonna need a camera guy
well so make yourself useful will ya
absolutely think of it as an opportunity
to pay me back for everything i do for
you
of course or everything i let you do to
me to be
i don't know the difference oh my gosh
ashley i can't believe we finally get to
meet in person
hi well if it isn't polly bendelson
herself
it's great to meet you girlfriend this
is so exciting
i've wanted to collab with you ever
since i first saw your quickie pick
paige
believe me the feeling is mutual it's a
huge opportunity for us both
by the way i'd like you to meet my
friend here he's my new camera guy
hi markiplier here hello oh my
what a handsome young man i know i'm
paulie
hello i'm delighted to make you
acquaintance of course i'm a youtuber
it's not the same as whatever the hell
witchcraft site you were on but i bet
it's equivalent
i've never been to into de poona this is
your first time
how do you think rain is made all right
videography is one of my many many how
is that so
yes well i'm very much looking forward
to discovering your
other talents it's funny looking is
actually my other talent
you know what i forgot my tripod
hold on i'll be right back i'm here i
hold
camera i'll be your tripod take your
time girl
it's a chance for me to get to know your
cute friend better
let us know each other huh
hello that's weird why welcome the
honeybee isn't registering this chick
no wait there it goes huh that's never
happened before
must be a bug or something must be
anyway i'm getting a traditional vibe
from this broad
she's probably looking for a classy guy
so try to wait
at least 10 [ __ ] seconds before you
whip your dick out
okay yes my other talent is
counting you're a teletuber hey
i grew up on teletubbies yes sir
it'll be almost four years now since i
started making videos
uh-huh i run a beauty channel called
polly's paradise great you ever hear of
it
no usually just say watch people play
video games you ever seen that
this is a perfectly valid way to spend
time
i could never figure out how those
things work needed somebody to teach me
well i could teach you all right
got the tripod ready to go scouting for
a good location
they call me the tripod i sure am
oh will your cute friend be joining us
uh more than two yep
we wouldn't want to be out there without
a decent camera guy would we
no why is tripod man me hello
hi hello a talk
forgive me but i'm dying to know more
about you
of course is there anything you do in
the shower to keep yourself entertained
absolutely i usually go inward into my
own thoughts and i let myself sink
deeper into the cosmos that is the
interior of my mind
eternally seeking self-validation
amongst all the various memories
that come flooding forwards of all the
embarrassing moments of my life
repeating endlessly on loop
and usually i'll start sitting down in
the shower at this point as i feel the
rain
falling slowly down through my hair and
dripping onto my naked body as i caress
myself into a bowl
and then collapse inwardly as i'm
externally spiraling downward
into the everlasting chance of my mind
and then i use soap
floats your boat did you know boats
float from displacement
that's a fun fact go ahead ask me
anything i
will nothing to hide what's your name
what
is how it's weather i want to know how
this rain
thing happens i used to love
thunderstorms when i was a kid
there's just something so cozy about it
good answer but if me too but you know
it's weird that rain falls from the sky
right
that's strange let's figure out what's
going on inside that cute head of you
if you can figure it out would you
rather your partner be good in the
kitchen
all good in the bedroom are these
mutually exclusive answers are you mean
good like making the bed well i'd
rather ever be good in the boardroom
good with finances not really my style
well it's why you asked me you know it
was why you asked
me what you thought it's you know if i
was asking you you
your answer would be valid and i would
accept it because it would be your
answer but considering it was my answer
i don't really see why you're
questioning it hello
[ __ ] i can't believe i haven't asked you
this yet what
have you ever tried to suck your own
dick never
felt the need to but maybe you know
i think it's a mystery right it's like
schrodinger's penis you never know
until you try but if you try you'll
never
know right it sucked and not sucked
all at once i'm a bit of a philosopher
or successfully i might add you actually
got it
[ __ ] i've been trying to suck my tits
for years
well that's chump change compared to
dick
sucking let's go on a date we're gonna
lay around and do nothing
but i guess that can wait funnily enough
that's all i'm asking you to do
i'll match all the colors myself and
then a fruit will erupt out of you
oh fancy wow is this how you get all the
girls to fall for you
yes
get stamina yeah six stamps
lovely indeed it's the love token and
you'll also
get one of these
[Music]
you know how when your computer starts
to work harder you can
hear the fan kick up if i put the
microphone close enough to my head
[Music]
that's what my brain sounds like i'm tr
i know there are three matches i'm
trying to set up for bigger matches
[Music]
you're gonna blush all right
it's not my brain it's the air
conditioner shut up i'm having
passion
that's my secret i'm always
oh cocky oh my
indeed oh me oh my oh it's
on now you thought mercy was a thing in
my definition dictionary
good heavens great heavens best heavens
give me the seeds
give me the fruit give me the fruit give
me the fruit
i feel like the luckiest girl in the
world well
you should you realize what i did
to get to this moment here yeah what do
you think
do we have enough usable footage oh yeah
is this a video is this a video send the
footage over to your editor by the end
of the week
were we filming a video here i'll let
you know when we just recorded the video
to go live
sounds good to me and uh
hey if you're interested maybe there's
something else we can collaborate on too
maybe hey now really
whatever do you have in mind well
you know maybe oh wow way does that
include me am i okay
i can see you're definitely getting the
hang of these double dates yeah i would
have gotten the last one
the honeybee was able to determine that
these two kind of have the hots for each
other
uh-huh but threesomes don't just happen
you know
you gotta be in the right place at the
right time right
naturally the honeybees got you covered
there too
just keep an eye on the girlfinder app
it'll alert you when there's a perfect
opportunity for a second date
you can't miss it okay or what that is
handy
the guys at honeycorp think of
everything hoonicorp is the place to be
all right i'm done here i'm leaving
goodbye
i'm going back to my hotel room screw
you
both using me for content
hey what are you doing here
shouldn't you be nads deep in some kind
of hole right now
yeah well you know uh where's the photo
album craig on the
wardrobe stand your obsession with
dressing girls up
but i do understand it
still good glad we're on the same page
whatever okay whatever we got here
70s 70s 80s
punk rock skater girl punk skater girl
punk rock skater skate punk
skate punk anyway okay that's the first
episode
of hunipop 2 double date hope you
enjoyed it remember
this never happened it was all the fever
dream
and if it continues it's just a case of
you going back into the same dream
so don't you worry about it thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to really see the amount of
emotional
maturity that i have reached in the time
in between these
watch the original series and compared
to now i'd love to hear your notes on
the matter
i think you'll find that i'm much more
dignified and refined and
intelligent and uh respectful
i look forward to hearing your notes on
this and seeing the rich detail of how
i've matured thank you again
and as always i will see you in the next
video
[Music]
bye-bye
you